[Music]
guess what Kelly told me last night she
and Ben are selling their home it's a
beautiful property
great location new kitchen I think
they'll give us the listing happy great
honey
we can't be realtor's if we don't have
listings oh [ __ ] someone's coming hurry
act casual our life was amazing but
something happened to my wife I can't
feel my heartbeat what she threw up this
I didn't have formaldehyde so I said to
in olive oil that was a crazy man
embalming well I'm not a medical expert
it was a huge amount she's acting
different I can cook that for you
sweetheart
I'm fine did mom die
she is dead and also Undead some guy I
don't like that word I think it's
inherently negative I don't like it
either let's not use it I do like the
way that I feel I have endless energy
and I sleep 2 hours a night I get so
much done you eat people I know it's
just that I'm so much more confident I
can parallel park in one move now the
undead are completely driven by their it
but if I can't control myself and I risk
everything that matters to me but within
us that's any up to do this alone
sweetheart not gonna bail on you no we
have to kill someone who deserves
I guess the prototype would be a young
single Hitler God we'd be heroes
[Music]
this time no
you guys are not great at this all my
life done there are now on we [ __ ]
everything up together
yeah what kind of realtor are you
residential but commercial on request
[Music]
you
[Music]
supercool go brown right this job is my
one shot it saved me my marriage what
are you wearing my uniform it's like
you're three beers too intimate Alma
tough motorcycle cop
I got no